[Music]
[Applause]
Paul fine bomb the voice of the SEC Paul
fine bomb show and uh let's see it's uh
Georgia Tennessee coming up this weekend
uh SEC nation is live Saturday mornings
at 10:00 a.m. eastern Paul you're having
too much fun you are there's too many
topics and you're having you're having a
field day here would the Jim Harbaugh
situation happen in the
SEC
no and and part of the reason Dan is
that the SEC doesn't do everything right
but they do keep things pretty button
down and this blew up uh about 13 years
ago there was remember when Lane kein
yes that lane kein went to Tennessee he
immediately called out Urban Meyer for
being a cheater which was great theater
I know it even got to your uh uh studio
and it went on for a while and it turned
out that he was
wrong uh so anyway there move the
calendar up uh we're we're now in May at
the SEC spring meetings in dtin and
there's this room with with at the time
I think there were 12 sec head coaches
and the commissioner Mike Slide the guy
Mike was you know intellectual law law
lawyer 59
139 PBS kind of I think I was describing
myself there and uh he uh they're in the
room uh and and and kein and urban start
going at it and finally SL just slammed
his fist through the
table and and he and he and he and and
Lane interrupted and he said effing shut
up lane and the room went quiet and I'm
I'm told reliably that Nick Savin and
Urban Meyer had the biggest grins in the
the room and that was it uh he said
we're not doing this anymore he said if
you got a problem you call me you don't
go public and interestingly Dan there's
been a lot of accusations privately but
we and I'm not saying this is right I'm
just saying this is the way it has been
the SEC buttoned down and no longer was
a was a civil war just like what we're
seeing in the Big 10 okay but we had
this moment you know what was it last
year the year before with Jimbo Fisher
and Nick Sabin and I know where the
bodies are buried and but it it died it
died uh because because it got the
commissioner buttoned it down and said
enough and by the way who won that
battle between Sav and Jimbo but but no
reporters really followed up no uh and
I'm not advocating that you know my
background uh that drives me crazy uh
but it it's almost a new normal and I
I'm not suggesting uh before anybody
jumps to too many conclusions that that
cheating is tolerated it it's they just
deal with it in a different way and I
think even the Big 10 has done that most
most conferences do that that's why this
is such an outlier and the antagonism
from Michigan toward petiti Tony petiti
last week was was really surprising and
shocking and I know everybody's joking
what if petiti has to give the trophy in
two weeks to u to harau I mean you've
been there you you've done the trophy
celebrations at the Super Bowl when when
there was animus toward uh Roger Goodell
and others and it's just uh it's amazing
especially when you look at uh the
University president at at Michigan
Santo Ono who's fairly new on the job
and he's I mean I I feel expect next
Saturday him him to you know you lead
the team in out of the tunnel uh waving
pom poms with some of the comments that
he's been making what do you expect to
happen tomorrow at this hearing with
Harbaugh I mean I think if you
use practical legal uh knowledge they
won't give it but then again U if if
this was in Tuscaloosa if this was in
Columbus Ohio would it be granted yes it
would be you think
so if if this was heard in Columbus
would Michigan no I mean I excuse me I
mean if if it had been Ryan day and
Columbus or okay okay yeah no please no
I I think I think the hometown nature
and and I we all want to believe uh that
that judges are Beyond reproach but I
don't know I've been reading a lot about
the Supreme Court lately that makes me
wonder if if they can't be influenced
what bothers you the most about this
cheating
scandal uh Michigan
fans uh
it because that's who I I mean I I mean
Harbaugh is Harbaugh I mean you know his
press conference the other day was was
classic Jim Harbaugh didn't make any
sense a lot of non seers but that's who
he is um but the the fan reaction and
and and some of the sicker fans who have
stood up for them uh and I know a lot of
people in the in the media business you
know are trying to put this as a fox
versus ESPN deal I don't nobody's
telling people at ESPN what to say I can
assure you of that um I I don't know if
you could say the same thing about what
we hear on Fox is this are you connected
to Fox before I get too deep into the uh
just great I don't have any you know I
whatever you to say you say I mean it's
just it's just kind it's comical to to
watch that show on Saturday and and
to listen I mean to listen to Urban
Meyer of all people shill for Michigan I
I mean I I mean that that's beyond the
pale well you have Desmond Howard on
your
roster well I'm I'm going to uh okay how
much I respect Des of course you do of
course what a fine what a fine teammate
he is but I did appreciate his legal
advice the other day on on get up I I I
thought that was very helpful for my uh
my law practice uh
Harbaugh they don't have um the compass
doesn't Point towards them admitting
anything like they're a victim they're
America's team due
process uh but it still feels like they
they did something wrong they just don't
want to be punished this way for doing
something wrong Dan they did something
wrong uh whether Harbaugh or ordered it
or not he's responsible that that's what
the rule book says whether you like the
rules of the NCAA or not and I don't uh
and you know I have friends who say well
the NCA is out to get them but if you go
back if if Jim Harbaugh had just agreed
to dismiss whatever these allegations
were during covid level two allegate it
would be over but he wouldn't I mean Jim
Harbaugh just I mean so calcitrin uh he
he just wouldn't admit to doing anything
I mean he's one of those we all know
people like that from high school until
right now that that will never admit
that they're wrong and that that's what
gets him in trouble every time and I I
think he you know whether the the NCAA
had an exra grind or not uh I mean he
pushed them to this point but I think
all these other coaches coming in you
hear from coaches I hear from coaches
and they all believe uh the ones I hear
from I should say uh that that Harbaugh
gained not not a slight Advantage but
but a significant advantage and and and
and something should be done and and I
frankly don't think a three- game
suspension is that big of a deal even
even considering the weight of next
week's game I think if petiti had turned
his head then it would have looked
ridiculous uh I I I applaud him for
doing it uh and and and whether it goes
anywhere from here it probably won't
because the NCAA is not really equipped
any longer to to do an investigation
under three or four years if Michigan
wins the national title will you
recognize them as national champs I will
refuse to recognize Michigan as the
national champs uh I I just I I was
taught uh that that Athletics should be
an even playing field uh and to me they
they are not subscribing to that do you
have are you on the side of the NCAA or
James
Madison James Madison uh I mean I I know
that this sounds contradictory but
they're two different situations with
James Madison I mean the I mean why
can't the president of the
NCAA Dan Charlie Baker this everybody
loves this guy he's a governor of
Massachusetts why can't he just say
listen I don't care what you guys are
saying down the hall I am making an
executive decision and allowing James
Madison uh to compete in postseason
they've earned it and some Antiquated
rule uh that should have been changed I
I am simply throwing out I mean the NCAA
did this in the in the sanduski case
they they literally did not follow any
of their own rules R well I'm I'm
wondering James Madison is playing
everybody in their conference they're
the best team in their conference yeah
they can't compete for the conference
Championship and they're not bull El I
it just you're holding a hearing why
hold a hearing if you're going to you
know say you're you're going to say that
this is the rule and we're not changing
the rule listen I'm for rules but there
comes a point when you just can't be uh
the head Master uh in 1957 and and and
suspend people because uh you know they
looked at you the wrong way you have to
use common sense that is not the case in
Harbaugh uh but it is the case in JMU
and it's just another example of why
people hate the
NCAA was last week a good week for Texas
A&M no but I think it was necessary and
you know we're talking about $77 million
I mean it was it was it was
self-inflicted but In fairness and I
know this will sound crazy but the ad
was not the ad that hired Jimbo the ad
that hired Jimbo guess was trying to
hire Jimbo again I mean can you imagine
if he'd gotten stuck with him twice uh
to LSU and and and A&M did not want to
lose the momentum and and and Dan I know
I know everybody you know is working
hard trying to make a living but in in
Texas $77 million is really not a lot of
money that that's just a good day in the
oil Market uh so they covered it well
is this a big time job is ANM a big time
job I think it can be uh and I've been
there so many times and I've seen it is
it is set up perfectly and I I threw
this out the other day and people
scoffed I thought a guy like dabos
Sweeney would be perfect there uh he's a
he's a he's somewhat narrow-minded he
fits the culture in terms of button down
uh he he's been late to the portal he's
been late to nil but but he's a good
football coach and he also been the six
playoffs and has won two national champ
Championship it's not the same as
bringing a beaten down Jimbo Fisher from
Florida State I mean davo has some
issues I mean he's frustrated I because
he doesn't have Trevor Lawrence and he
doesn't have DeShaun Watson uh but I I
think someone like that would work I I
think that it's a very important
selection though if they blow this then
where do they go and I mentioned this
yesterday if the analyst who are friends
with Dion really care about Dion they
should stop putting him up for jobs
because now you have recruits were
backing away you had two fourstar
recruits who you know pulled out with
their commitment reopen uh their
recruitment here Dion hasn't shown me
anything this year that leads me to
believe okay he's a great coach he'll be
able to run Colorado was desperate Dion
put him on the map and made him relevant
but I got to I got to wait let me see a
little bit here before we go man we had
him going to the Cowboys a couple of
weeks ago well again you know I'm on
some of their show when Stephen A Smith
pops up and mentions that um and it's
great I mean but Dion first of all he
can't take his son he can't he can't
take the best players because they can't
just keep moving every year uh you you
you have you only have so many Mulligans
in your in your repertoire to get around
uh I mean I think if he stays another
year and shows Improvement then yeah I
do I do think he's a a change agent but
but not moving after after one year and
if they only four wins or five wins this
year could you see a bowl I mean they're
there still musty TV I would think
because of him and his son but um and I
know the Pack 12 has a rule that you
have have at least six wins but could
you see could you see somebody going
nope we're bringing in color how about
Colorado versus James Madison yeah I
think by the way you can get in with
five Dan the APR that's about your
aptitude and your your you know your GPA
whatever uh if your bowl allotments are
are deficient and I don't know whether
they are or not in that League they'll
be somewhere that they could they could
conceivably get into a bowl and I think
they should I think that's Four Winds
though Four Winds could they no they I
think they'll need they're in a pool
they they'll need to have five otherwise
they would qualify Colorado
JMU what do you think I like it um and
you know maybe we can get Ric Flair to
do the game out sure
yeah um okay I want you to bet on
Harbaugh status when they run out of the
tunnel where's Jim Harbaugh on Saturday
uh I don't think he's going to be there
uh if I'm if if what I learned about law
growing up my seventh grade civics class
comes
true what about him in uh coming out of
the tunnel against Ohio State yeah no I
think Tom Mars is a whole ball of wax
okay yeah I don't I don't think you can
come back once the uh once they if the
judge agrees to it then he's free uh but
if he says no uh then I don't think uh
he can do it so uh I mean if so if
Harbaugh doesn't if he's not able to
coach does does ESPN ask him to be the
the the celebrity guest picker
on wow wow you should have saved that
one for your show well no this show is
much bigger than anything I I do in the
afternoon uh safe travels great to talk
to you again Paul thank you thank you
Dan always Paul fine bomb ESPN radio
host the Paul fine bomb show live
weekdays from 3:00 to 7:00 eastern on
SEC network